I'm Amber wise I am a cannabis scientist
and I'm here today to answer your
questions from Twitter this is cannabis
support
[Music]
from I'm Felicia ho it's okay to smoke
weed but every day some people use
cannabis to modulate neurodivergent
behaviors some people use it medically
in order to get out of bed and reduce
their pain some people use it for
arthritis and and these are daily
applications and there are zero deaths
attributed to Natural cannabis use some
would argue that getting high every day
is potentially safer than getting drunk
every day from 50 Shades of Green why
does weed cause the munchies
cannabinoids and THC actually stimulate
the release of our hunger molecule
called gorillin a hormone that makes us
feel hungry cannabinoids can also
heighten your sense of smell and taste
so not only do you feel more hungry but
those Doritos can also taste better next
up rapid RNR asks did you know the human
body naturally produces cannabinoids the
thing is our body does make cannabinoid
molecules but they're not the same ones
that the plant makes these molecules
regulate almost every aspect of our
biochemistry history mood sleepiness and
awakeness how hungry you are your
metabolism rates your energy levels we
call this now the endocannabinoid system
the reason that we react to the
cannabinoids that the plant makes are
because those molecules also bind to the
same receptors that our body has in our
endocannabinoid system from terrible
Tony is it me or is the weed out here
getting stronger humans are now
selectively breeding cannabis and have
been for a long time to make more
cannabinoids in the flower flower from
30 40 years ago has fewer cannabinoids
than the flower that's being grown today
you might be going into retail stores
and seeing you know a couple years ago
labels saying 25 total THC in flour and
now we're seeing 35 or maybe 40 percent
or even more than 40 percent those
numbers are not real there is a physical
limit to the amount that the plant can
make 30 percent is generally agreed upon
as the maximum amount that you can get a
flower to produce and that is like the
dankiest sticky icky we're talking about
the next question is from alms XO is
weed a psychedelic there are three terms
I'd like to define a little more clearly
here we have psychoactive psychotropic
and we have psychedelic psychoactive is
anything that reacts with your brain
chemistry and that can be caffeine that
can be any number of things psychotropic
is somehow affecting your perception of
reality your mood your awareness and
sometimes perception of time and
psychedelic is generally agreed upon to
include hallucinations and drastic
changes in how you're perceiving reality
in terms of the generally agreed upon
definition of psychedelic generally
cannabinoids are not THC and CBD can be
considered psychoactive they both
interact with our brains and generally
THC is considered psychotropic it can
change our mood and and how we perceive
reality from anthology does CBD actually
do anything first I want to show how
similar CBD and THC are in terms of
molecular structure they actually weigh
the same and have the same number of
carbons and hydrogens and oxygens the
big difference is that the ring
structure here is closed on the THC and
the ring is open here on the CBD that's
the only difference however we have it
on paper here so they both look flat in
three dimensions the shape is quite
different and that leads to different
behaviors in your body purified CBD all
by itself is often not very effective
for whatever you might be seeking
treatment for however when we have a
more full spectrum mixture of different
molecules from the plant it can be much
more effective for a variety of
different ailments from filth filler why
do Edibles hit different well it's
because it's actually a different
molecule that your body is getting high
from so so far we've really only been
talking about Delta 9 THC and that's
what happens when you inhale it goes
directly into your bloodstream from your
lungs so you feel that effect quite
quickly however with Edibles you first
have to go through your stomach your
intestines through your liver and your
liver attaches a hydroxy group and
causes a different molecule to form
called 11-hydroxy THC that's why Edibles
hit different meaning they take longer
and they also feel different because
it's a different molecule interacting
with those receptors in your body from
Jada Tony raw what's the difference
between indoor and outdoor weed this is
a very hot topic and everybody falls on
one side or the other there was a recent
study done where they grew clones from
the same plant so genetically the same
starting material some of them were
grown outdoors in natural living soil
some of it was grown indoors with
potting soil and artificial lights and
looking at the molecular profile that
the plant made the outdoor cannabis had
wider variety of cannabinoids it had
more minor cannabinoids and rare
cannabinoids and the indoor often has
slightly higher yield and often more
consistent molecular profiles so it
really depends on what you're looking
for and you can get quality out of both
types of situations from cine churros
why does weed smell like that cannabis
has that distinctive smell and different
strains do smell differently but you can
often say that that smells like weed
well the answer is terpenes terpenes are
one of the most widely found molecules
in the plant kingdom all kinds of plants
and herbs and spices and pine trees have
terpenes in them THC and CBD actually
are odorless and in fact the drug dogs
that are used to detect cannabis are
trained on terpene molecules and that
skunky smell in cannabis is actually due
to sulfur containing compounds that were
just very recently discovered from
Robin's Group LLC what are cannabis
trichomes and why are they so important
can cannabis trichomes are actually only
found on the female structure of the
flower and the trichomes are where all
of the cannabinoids and terpenes are
synthesized in the plant if you zoom in
you'll see these trichomes are these
tiny little mushroom shaped structures
and within that round part at the end of
that stock that's the location that the
plant actually makes the cannabinoids
THC CBD and the terpenes all in that one
little head from finger zero zero is
there really a difference between indica
and sativa or is it all on the head the
old adage is that Indica will make you
feel into couch or relaxed or sleepy and
sativas might make you more creative or
more energetic recent studies actually
show that there is no molecular
correlation between the two in terms of
the kinds of terpenes or cannabinoid
molecules that the plant makes so it
might actually just be all in your head
from next big crop what effect does THC
and CBD have on your sleep and dreams so
in terms of falling asleep and staying
asleep THC and CBD in combination seem
to work quite well cannabis and THC and
cannabinoids can help with falling
asleep in terms of Dreams there is
evidence to suggest that THC reduces
your REM Cycles which is the part where
you remember your dreams occurring but
long-term users of cannabis who stop
using do report very vivid dreams coming
back after they're stopping using
cannabis so there is definitely some
effect on what we remember during use
and after we stop using but we don't
fully understand the mechanisms there
from optimal nt1 why does marijuana have
THC and the plant doesn't actually make
these molecules for our benefit the
plant benefits from making these
molecules what we call secondary
metabolites something that are not
needed for fundamental growth and
function of plants but perform another
Fung function there is evidence to
suggest it protects against UV rays it
protects potentially against pests and
also things like anti-fungal and
antimicrobial properties Amy 99 why does
weed make you high we used to think it
was dopamine being released but it's
actually not true science has shown that
it is this anandamide molecule named for
the Sanskrit word Joy or Bliss this
molecule is released in our brain and
makes us feel happy sometimes it can
make us feel anxious or moody or
paranoid as well is determined by your
biochemistry and many other factors
including what other molecules are
present potentially in that cannabis the
next question is from Danny T Kane have
we determined if contact high is a real
thing never in my life have I got a
contact high in terms of contact high
we're going to talk about you know
inhaling secondhand smoke at a party
let's say one study that was done with a
bunch of folks in a very unventilated
room where half the folks smoked joints
constantly and the other half's just sat
there the people who did not smoke the
joints tested positive for THC and said
they felt a little high when they just
ventilated the room the folks who did
not smoke the joints said they didn't
feel much and they also did not test
positive for THC whiffing the smell of
cannabis as you walk down the street
you're totally fine but if your friends
are hot boxing in the car you might run
into some problems from Kate white
what's the difference between Delta 8 9
and 10. to a chemist it's really just
the position of a double bond this is
Delta 9 THC and this is a double bond
here between the nine and ten carbon
atoms here Delta eight means this double
bond is just over here on the ring
structure and Delta 10 means it's on a
different position on that same ring the
big difference is that Delta 9 THC is
naturally produced by the plant and
Delta 8 and Delta 10 are converted from
either CBD molecules or Delta 9. the
next question is from
I why does weed make you laugh well
there is actually a mechanism in that it
makes more blood flow to the prefrontal
cortex of your brain which affects your
moods it does increase the
endocannabinoid Bliss molecules in our
in our bodies the anandamide molecule
that naturally exists so it's
complicated but there is some chemistry
behind it making you laugh from 420 Weed
Man Jeff one question does anybody know
where cannabis originated from and about
how long ago we used to say that
cannabis came from the Central Asian
region usually around India and in fact
cannabis Indica Indica suggests coming
from India but it turns out genetic
profiling recently in the last couple of
years shows that it comes from East Asia
and Eastern parts of China how long ago
well plants predate humans there is
evidence to suggest that there was fiber
type hemp and cannabis being grown about
12 000 BC's psychotropic and spiritual
use of cannabis around 7 500 years ago
and there have been documented evidence
of its medical and ritualistic use for
thousands of years and in various parts
of the world commercially available
cannabis is so highly bred that it would
be difficult to kind of Trace that back
or even be very recognizable to sort of
the origins of the cannabis plant the
next question is from Martini no tea why
does weed still need to give you dry
mouth do we have people working on this
we need people working on this there are
neurotransmitters in our brains that
cannabinoids interact with that cause
our saliva glands to stop working as
well as they should and it's not just
smoking you can get cottonmouth from
Edibles and tinctures as well in terms
of we should have somebody working on
this this is one of the things that gets
me excited about the Cannabis world of
science is that there's so many
unanswered questions and potential areas
for new research so somebody should get
it on that at Pontiac made ddg is weed
addictive addiction is generally defined
as a use disorder now and involves some
sort of physical withdrawal symptoms
when use is stopped it's an estimated
between 10 and 30 percent of cannabis
users end up with some sort of use
disorder and certainly people seek
treatment for cannabis use disorder but
it's generally much lower than for other
drugs of abuse compared to the number of
people that use cannabis cannabis is
being shown to be a way to get off of
other types of drugs like opiates it's
not an easy yes or no answer but
generally much safer than other types of
recreational drugs out there from Ashley
logic how exactly does marijuana help
cancer multiple sclerosis and glaucoma
specifically for cancer many people
think that cannabis products can reduce
tumor growth and the clinical studies on
that are quite mixed actually cannabis
has been shown to help with the
treatment of Cancer and a lot of the
side effects that come from chemotherapy
and radiation making you feel hungry
which is important to keep your
nutrition up I'm helping you sleep and
relax which is good for healing and the
nausea that you can sometimes get with a
chemotherapy the glaucoma aspect seems
to be more short-term and not really a
cure cannabis and THC does reduce the
intraocular pressure certainly there are
many Ms patients that are being helped
with specific formulations you know
under a doctor's care from Mike in mahea
so why is cannabis still classified as
schedule one drug out of five schedules
one being the most dangerous who is
obstructing rescheduling this is pretty
much just a hangover from the
prohibition era schedule one means there
is no accepted medical benefit we which
we know is not true anymore the DEA is
the one that controls the scheduling and
the FDA has purview over all the Food
and Drugs in the United States currently
they're sort of pointing fingers at each
other and saying it's you know one or
the other's fault but it is important to
remember that rescheduling down to a
different number on the scheduling scale
is different than descheduling which is
removing it all together from the
scheduling scale in my opinion it would
be better to deschedule altogether if
you have it on the numbered schedule
scale that pretty much limits it to
pharmaceutical and prescription
applications only and there are also
legal and social justice issues that are
wrapped up in the scheduling system
versus removing it from that list
altogether from fat one bear why does
weed turn purple these purple molecules
are due to molecules called anthocyanins
a lot of plants produce anthocyanins
when they are in cold environments
anthocyanins are also known to be UV
protein hectors so when there's too much
sun these anthocyanin molecules can
absorb some of that extra UV energy so
often we see more purple plants when
it's colder and more sunny and they can
revert to being more green when it warms
up again but some of it is also due to
genetics from River Rock Co what's the
difference between resin live resin and
rosin some people consider resin to be a
specific kind of extract of the cannabis
plant but resin can be used as a general
term for all kinds of sticky oils or
extracts that come from the plant itself
live resin is generally agreed upon to
be extracted from fresh frozen plant
material the cannabis plant is grown and
harvested like normal but it doesn't get
dried it gets flash frozen and that all
of that water content and original
terpene profile is maintained and then
rosin is actually just pressed oil from
the plant itself so there's no solvents
no traction being done but heat and
pressure being applied to the dried
flower buds and the cannabinoids and
terpenes and other kind of oily plant
molecules oozing out as like a thick
oily substance all right that's all the
questions hope you learned something and
until next time
[Music]